en este vídeo vamos a hablar de niveles
de significancia los cuales se denotan
con la letra griega alfa y vamos a
hablar de dos cosas las diferentes
conclusiones a las que se pueden llegar
con base en los diferentes niveles de
significancia que establezcamos y
también hablaremos de la importancia
desde un punto de vista ético de
establecer estos niveles de
significancia antes de realizar el
experimento y calcular los valores p
para ayudarnos veamos el siguiente
ejemplo en el cual se plantea que raúl
escuchó que hacer girar una moneda sobre
su eje en lugar de lanzarla al aire
aumenta la probabilidad por encima del
50% de que la moneda caiga mostrando
cara lo cual es bastante fascinante sí
es cierto
pruebo esto haciendo girar 10 veces 10
monedas distintas lo que da un total de
100 repeticiones su hipótesis nula era
que la proporción no cambia si haces
girar la moneda en comparación con
lanzarla al aire es decir un 50 por
ciento y su hipótesis alternativa es que
la proporción de caer en cara es mayor
que el 50% al hacer girar la moneda
donde p es el valor real de la
proporción de monedas que caen en cara
cuando se hacen tirar de las 100
repeticiones la moneda cayó en cara a 59
veces raúl calculó que el estadístico y
esta es la proporción muestral es que 59
de las 100 veces fueron caras lo que es
igual a 0.59 lo que calculo que tiene un
valor p asociado de aproximadamente 0
punto cero
y 6 así que con base en los resultados
obtenidos si estableces de antemano un
nivel de significancia de 0.05 a qué
conclusiones puede llegar y mientras
pausas el vídeo piensa si podrían o no
ser diferentes si establece de antemano
su nivel de significancia en 0.01 pausa
el vídeo e intenta encontrar la
respuesta
primero recordemos que es el valor p
podemos considerarlo como la
probabilidad de obtener una proporción
muestral al menos de este valor si
suponemos que la hipótesis nula es
verdadera y si éste es lo
suficientemente bajo es decir si está
por debajo de un cierto umbral que es
justo nuestro nivel de significancia
entonces rechazaremos nuestra hipótesis
nula
en este escenario podemos ver que 0
puntos 0 36 o nuestro valor p es en
efecto menor que alfa es menor que 0.05
y por esta razón podemos rechazar
nuestra hipótesis nula
en un lenguaje cotidiano rechazar la
hipótesis nula es rechazar la noción de
que el valor real de la proporción de
monedas que caen en karam cuando se
hacen girar es de 50% y si rechazamos la
hipótesis nula entonces podemos sugerir
nuestra hipótesis alternativa que nos
dice que el valor real de la proporción
de monedas que caen en kadam cuando se
hace el girar es mayor que el 50%
ahora qué pasará si se establece un
nivel de significancia menor bueno en
esta situación
nuestro valor p es decir nuestra
probabilidad de obtener este estadístico
muestral si suponemos verdadera la
hipótesis nula es mayor o igual que
nuestro umbral es decir que nuestro
nivel de significancia en este caso
podemos decir que no se rechaza la
hipótesis nula lo que quiere decir que
no podemos rechazar lo que establecimos
aquí y por lo tanto no podemos sugerir
la hipótesis alternativa así que debido
a la diferencia entre lo que podemos
concluir dados estos niveles de
significancia es muy importante que se
establezcan de antemano ya que podemos
imaginar que si eres algún tipo de
investigador es parte de la condición
humana querer tener un resultado
interesante
querrás descubrir algo querrás contarle
a tus amigos
oigan se puede sugerir mi hipótesis
alternativa podemos rechazar esta
suposición el status quo he encontrado
algo que hace la diferencia entonces es
muy tentador para el investigador
calcular los valores p y decir bueno tal
vez nadie notará si establezco después
mi nivel de significancia lo
suficientemente alto para poder rechazar
mi hipótesis nula hacer esto es muy poco
ético en vídeos futuros consideraremos
cómo elegir el nivel de significancia
con la anticipación como establecemos
este umbral de antemano dicho de otra
manera cuando debe de ser punto 01
cuando debe de ser punto 05 cuando punto
1 o cualquier valor